PICK UP WHERE YOU LEFT OFF.
ON LAURA INGRAHAM AND THIS IS
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" FROM
WASHINGTON TONIGHT.
THE BIDEN JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS
GETTING SO DESPERATE THEY'VE NOW
GONE NUCLEAR.
"THE ANGLE" WILL EXPLAIN IN
MOMENTS.
ONE FBI AGENT SWEPT INTO
MAR-A-LAGO AND MONDAY, THEY WERE
MET BY PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
ATTORNEY.
IF SHE'S IN MOMENTS WITH
RESPONSE TO MERRICK GARLAND.
BUT FIRST, SPIN CYCLE CRASH,
THAT'S TONIGHT'S FOCUS OF
TONIGHT'S "ANGLE."
CAN YOU IMAGINE WHAT
PRESIDENT XI OR PUTIN OR
TERRORISTS WHO WISH TO STRIKE
AGAINST AMERICA?
THIS IS THE AMERICA THAT THEY
USE TO FEAR.
TO SPEAK I PERSONALLY APPROVE
THE DECISION TO SEEK A SEARCH
WARRANT IN THIS MATTER.
FAITHFUL ADHERENCE TO THE RULE
OF LAW IS THE BEDROCK PRINCIPLE
OF THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND OF
OUR DEMOCRACY.
UPHOLDING THE RULE OF LAW MEANS
APPLYING THE LAW EVENLY, WITHOUT
FEAR, OR FAVOR.
OF UNDER MY WATCH, THAT'S
PRECISELY WHAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS DOING.
>> Laura: DOESN'T HE LOOK LIKE
A GUY WHO GOT A LOT OF WEDGIES
IN SIXTH GRADE?
I'LL BE FOREVER GRATEFUL FOR
MITCH McCONNELL FOR KEEPING IT
OFF THE COURT.
HE SAID A LOT OF NOTHING,
CHANGING NO MINDS ABOUT THE
PROPRIETY OF THEIR RAID AND NOT
A SINGLE ONE.
WHAT WE WITNESSED IN THIS WEEK
IS A SHAM.
IT'S A TOTAL EMBARRASSMENT FOR
AMERICA.
PUTTING TRUMP ON THE VICE OF THE
CURRENT PRESIDENTS FBI IS WHAT
YOU WOULD EXPECT FROM RUSSIA'S
FSB, NOT A PROUD CONSTITUTIONAL
REPUBLIC.
THE SIGNAL TO THE WORLD'S
UNMISTAKABLE.
OUR 246-YEAR-OLD REPUBLICS BEING
PULLED APART AT THE SEAMS.
DICTATORS CAN NOW SAY LOOK, WE
TOLD YOU THE ENTIRE DEMOCRACY
THING WAS A SCAM.
TURNS OUT THEIR PRESIDENT CAN
TRY TO PUT HIS POLITICAL CRITICS
IN JAIL LIKE WE DO.
OUR PRESIDENT WHO TRADITIONALLY
IS KNOWN AS A LEADER OF THE FREE
WORLD HAS BECOME A
LAUGHINGSTOCK.
SO AFRAID OF HIS POLITICAL
NEMESIS THAT LET IT BE KNOWN TO
THE DOJ GOONS THAT THEY NEEDED
TO FINISH OFF TRUMP POLITICALLY
FOR GOOD.
REMEMBER AS WE TOLD YOU ON
MONDAY, IT WAS LAST WEEK AT
BIDEN'S PEOPLE USE THEIR
STENOGRAPHERS AT
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" TO PASSWORD
ONTO MERRICK GARLAND.
THEY REPORTED BIDEN PRIVATELY
COMPLAINED THAT HE WANTED ERIC
GARLAND TO ACT LIKE A PROSECUTOR
WHEN IT CAME TO TRUMP ON JANUAR.
MESSAGE RECEIVED.
BIDEN AND THE DOJ TOTALLY LOST
CONTROL OF THE NARRATIVE.
AFTER THE DRAMATIC MONDAY RAID,
THEY WERE POSITIVELY SHOCKED AND
STUNNED TO SEE REPUBLICANS
CLOSING RANKS.
THE UNPRECEDENTED HEAVY-HANDED
TACTICS.
A BACK-AND-FORTH OVER DOCUMENTS
AND THE PRESIDENT'S TEAM PAD
LOCKING A STORAGE ROOM AT THE
GOVERNMENT'S REQUEST.
THEN THEY SHOW UP MONTHS LATER
TO RUMMAGE AROUND FOR NINE
HOURS?
RESPECTED FIGURES IN THE G.O.P.
REJECTED OF THE TARGETING TYPE,
EVERYONE FROM THE FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT AND THE FORMER
DIRECTOR OF THE CIA, MARCO RUBIO
AND CHUCK BRADLEY.
EVERYONE INCLUDING
MERRICK GARLAND AND
CHRISTOPHER WRAY KNOW THAT THIS
GROUP IS NOT NECESSARILY A TRUMP
FAN.
FOR THEM TO ALL SPEAK OUT IN
UNISON IS A DISASTER FOR THE
DEMOCRATS.
IN A PERPETUAL SPIN CYCLE, THE
DOJ IS APPARENTLY NO -- THE
SKETCHY MAGISTRATE BRUCE RUN
HARD TO RELEASE THE SEARCH
WARRANT AND THE PROPERTY.
WE WILL SEE YOU WHAT WILL HAPPEN
WHEN IT COMES OUT.
BUT IN THE ABSENCE OF ACTUAL
FACT, WE HAVE UNVERIFIABLE
CLAIMS POPPING OUT ABOUT MOLD
INSIDE MAR-A-LAGO AND EARLIER
TODAY REPORTING PERHAPS THERE
WAS A SECRET SERVICE AGENT
WORKING ON TRUMP'S DETAIL.
LATE TONIGHT'S, THEY KNEW DOJ ON
INFORMATION LOOK LIKE THEY
LAUNDERED THEIR LATEST
JUSTIFICATION THROUGH
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
FBI AGENTS WERE SCOURING TRUMPS
RESIDENCE IN SEARCH OF NUCLEAR
EVIDENCE, DOCUMENTS.
IT COULD BE AN EMAIL, WHATEVER.
IT'S AN EXCUSE THEY WANT TO RUN
WITH FURTHER RATED TO, HOW COULD
THEY POSSIBLY JUSTIFY A LIGHTING
HILLARY CLINTON OFF THE HOOK
WHEN THEY WERE CLASSIFIED AT THE
HIGHEST LEVEL?
I GUESS WERE SUPPOSED TO BELIEVE
THAT THE ESTABLISHED THE
POSSIBLE CAUSE NECESSARY, LIKE
WERE SUPPOSED TO BELIEVE THAT
MERRICK GARLAND HAD AND APPROVE
THE RATE AT ALL AND THEY TRIED
TO SPIN THAT.
THAT'S THE LIE THEY SPREAD LAST
NIGHT AND TRY TO KEEP UP WITH ME
HERE.
SORRY, GENTLEMEN, BUT GIVEN YOUR
HISTORY WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO DO BETTER THAN
JUST TRUST US, WE BELIEVE IN THE
RULE OF LAW.
THE FACT OUR CIA AND FBI, DOJ
LOST MOST OF THE CREDIBILITY,
IT'S NOT FOX NEWS.
NOT THE FAULT OF TRAUMA, HIS
SUPPORTERS, THEY DIDN'T CREATE
MERRICK GARLAND'S PROBLEM OR
ENTER MCKAY'S PROBLEM.
THEY BROUGHT THIS ON THEMSELVES.
NO MATTER WHAT GARLAND OR THEY
MAY SAY, IT'S NOT NORMAL TO
WEAPONIZE THE ENTIRE POWER OF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AGAINST
ONE INDIVIDUAL.
THIS CASE, TRYING TO FIND ANY
TECHNICAL CHARGE THEY CAN TO
BRING AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP.
FOUR MONTHS BEFORE HE'LL LIKELY
ANNOUNCE ANOTHER WHITE HOUSE
RUN, HOW CONVENIENT.
HOW WITH THE DEMOCRATS REACT
WITH THE NEXT REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENT HOLDING THE SAME
TACTICS WITH KAMALA HARRIS'
LIFE?
WE KNOW THE ANSWER, THEY CRY
FOUL AND THEY CLAIM THAT THE
PRESIDENT AND THE DOJ WAS
SUBVERTING DEMOCRACY.
THE STANDARD GOING FORWARD HAS
TO BE THAT ADMINISTRATIONS WILL
ONLY PURSUE LEGALLY THEIR
OPPONENTS WHEN IT'S A REALLY BIG
DEAL, NO DRAGNET'S, EXPEDITIONS,
PRETEXTUAL SEARCHES.
SOME OR ALL OF THIS MAY HAVE
HAPPENED HERE.
THE CHANCE OF LOCKER OUTCOME
OUT, REMEMBER THAT DURING THE
TRUMP RALLIES IN 2016?
THEY WEAR THAT, THEY WERE A
CHANCE CHANCE DESIGNED TO MOCK
HILLARY AND THE SYCOPHANTIC
PRESS THAT COVERED FOR HER.
THE TRUMPET MILLIONS OF THE
SUPPORTERS WERE FURIOUS THEY
SEEM TO USE HER OFFICE TO
ADVANCE HER HUSBAND'S
FOUNDATION.
EVEN WHEN THEY BELIEVED ALL
THAT, TRUMP AFTER HE WAS ELECTED
SENT FBI AGENTS TO HER HOUSE?
OF COURSE NOT.
BECAUSE HIS FOCUS WAS ON MAKING
OUR COUNTRY BETTER, MORE
PROSPEROUS.
BUT NOW WE HAVE AN
ADMINISTRATION THAT HAS DECIDED
TO GO TO WAR AGAINST ALL OF US.
THEY HAVE UNLIMITED GOVERNMENT
RESOURCES AT THEIR DISPOSAL AND
THEY ARE DEPLOYING THEM AGAINST
TRUMP, AND THERE ABOUT THE
HIGHER 87,000 NEW IRS AGENTS TO
DEPLOY AGAINST ANYONE WHO
QUESTIONS THEM.
I HAVE NEWS FOR THEM.
THE CONSTITUTION GETS TO SAY WHO
RUNS FOR PRESIDENT, NOT
MERRICK GARLAND.
HUNTING TRUMP WILL ONLY HURT
THEM.
AT A TIME WHEN OUR FAMILIES ARE
FACING SUCH DAUNTING CHALLENGES
JUST MAKES ME WANT TO BURST OUT
IN TEARS.
WHERE IS BIDEN'S FOCUS AND
PASSION?
HE'S NOT FIXING ANY OF THIS.
IF IT'S ABOUT GRABBING AS MUCH
POWER FROM THE REGULAR PEOPLE
THAT HE CAN.
DO THEY CARE THAT THE WAGES
AREN'T KEEPING UP WITH
INFLATION?
NOT EVEN CLOSE?
IT MEANS OUR PEOPLE ARE GETTING
POORER EVERY WEEKEND EVERY
MONTH?
NO, THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THAT.
THEY JUST SPIN FAIRY TALES.
>> ZERO INFLATION LAST MONTH,
BUT PEOPLE WERE STILL HURTING.
>> THE LAST MONTH, OUR ECONOMY
HAS 0% INFLATION!
IN JULY, WE SAW A DROP IN GAS
PRICES AND A RANGE OF OTHER
GOODS LIKE CLOTHING AND AIRFARES
AND HOUSEHOLD APPLIANCES WHICH
MEANS MORE MONEY IN THE POCKETS
OF WORKING FAMILIES!
>> OUR GOAL IS TO HAVE THE
ECONOMY TRANSITION.
>> Laura: SPIN CRASH.
AMERICANS DON'T TRUST THE
GOVERNMENT BECAUSE THEY ARE BAD
PEOPLE.
WE DON'T TRUST THE GOVERNMENT
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT PROVING
WORTHY OF OUR TRUST.
STOP TREATING AMERICANS FROM THE
OTHER PARTY WITH SUSPICION, STOP
PRETENDING YOU BELIEVE IN
BORDERS AND START ENFORCING
THEM.
STOP LYING ABOUT THE TRUE STATE
OF THE ECONOMY, YOU JUST HEARD
IT.
IN FACT, WISH CASTING ABOUT
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN UKRAINE,
STOP LYING ABOUT THE INNATE
CHARACTER OF AMERICA, OR SYSTEM
IS NOT RACIST, YOU ARE.
FINALLY, ANNOUNCE PUBLICLY
YOU'RE DROPPING ALL OF THE LEGAL
HARASSMENT OF PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THEN PRESIDENT BIDEN, GO BEFORE
THE CAMERAS AND TELL OUR COUNTRY
ANY DISPUTES BETWEEN YOU AND
TRUMP ARE GOING TO BE DECIDED BY
THE